[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain the epic american
science fiction film called dune
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie dune is set in the year 10191
humans have unfolded many secrets of the
universe and now travel from planet to
planet different planets have turned
into different nations and are governed
by a single potisha emperor named shadam
korino the fourth the planets have
houses with their respective dukes who
in turn follow the orders of the emperor
shaddam one such planet is called
arrakis it is a harsh desert planet that
is the only source of a rare substance
called spice spice is a valuable
substance that extends human vitality
and is critical for interstellar travel
hence arrakis despite its harsh
conditions is considered the most
valuable planet in the known universe
because of this the noble houses are
eager to rule the planet at the
beginning of the movie a native of
arrakis named chaney narrates that they
have been ruled by the noble house
harkonnen for a long time the house
harkonnen is cruel to natives of arrakis
but the poor natives cannot fight house
harkonnen which is under the emperor
shaddam's control chani also says that
one day all of a sudden house
harkonnen's troops leave arrakis but she
is sure that the emperor is going to
send someone else to take their place
and exploit their resources the scene
then changes to another planet named
kaladan ruled by house atreides the
prince of etradi's paul wakes up from a
recurring dream he has breakfast with
his mother lady jessica who is also a
member of an organization called the
benejesseret bena jesserit is an
exclusive sisterhood organization whose
members have advanced physical and
mental abilities hence jessica also has
the power to manipulate people's minds
she has been training paul on the
organization's disciplines for a long
time thus paul has powers to see the
future and bears other unique powers
that he is yet to discover paul's father
leto who is also the duke of house
atreides has an important meeting with
the personnel from the landsrad the
political body representing all the
noble houses in the evening everyone in
atreides welcomes the vips who have
brought a note from the emperor sadam
himself the emperor who has recently
removed house harkonnen from maracas
wants atreides to take harkenin's place
he wants lato and his troops to be in
charge of mining the spice from arrakis
duke lato is apprehensive of the
situation but follows the emperor's
orders whilst in the meeting jessica
notices a member of the benedescerate
organization gaius helen mohaim staring
at paul the meeting ends when lato marks
a seal with his ring confirming that
they will follow the orders and go to
arrakis in the following scene we see
atreides troops preparing to leave for
arrakis among the troop is their bravest
soldier named duncan idaho who is also
paul's close friend paul has been
getting visions about duncan's death in
arrakis which he is worried about duncan
assures him that he will be fine and
leaves for the planet to prepare for
paul and the family's arrival the
following scene shows us paul and his
father lato talking about various
matters lato reveals he has no interest
in gaining wealth using the spice
instead he plans on befriending the
people of arrakis called the fremen
unlike the former duke harkonnen he
plans to treat the fremen with respect
so they can be a valuable asset to
atreides later paul and his associate
guernie halleck practice a duel they
both have wrist devices that creates a
layer of protective force around their
body halluck is worried that they will
be attacked by the jealous harkonnen so
he asks paul to be careful when they
reach arrakis elsewhere in the house of
harkonnen the former ruler of arrakis
baron harkinan and his rogue nephew
rabin talk about their last ship leaving
arrakis leaving the planet to the
atreides robin belittles the emperor for
taking them off arrakis and handing it
to the atreides but he is surprised when
the baron reveals that the emperor is
actually planning on the atreides
downfall because he is jealous of their
growing popularity the emperor's plan is
to kill lato and all his men while they
are mining spice in arrakis back on
caledon jessica wakes paul up and takes
him to a doctor to get his vitals
checked it turns out that the reverend
mother gaius helen mohayem has come to
know of paul's visions and wants to
check if he is the one they have been
waiting for she makes him put his hand
in a box to test his impulse control
which he passes with great effort after
mohaim leaves jessica tells paul that
the female organization benigeret has
been steering politics for years from
the shadows they have also carefully
been crossing bloodlines in order to
give birth to the one man who will have
the potential to save arrakis from spice
exploitation it turns out the test paul
just passed shows that he is potentially
the one they have been looking for the
messiah of arrakis the very next day
lato paul jessica and their troops leave
for arrakis and land on the planet they
are welcomed by the native fremen who
seem to already believe that paul is
their messiah who they refer to as muad
although paul himself believes that it
is just a superstition later he is in
his chamber learning about a species of
massive sand worms found on arrakis to
be safe from it the fremen walk in
irregular motions in the sand as paul
watches holograms a deadly insect
emerges from the wall and tries to kill
him but paul saves himself at the right
time upon investigation it is found that
a harkonnen soldier had been hiding in
the walls to kill paul the scene shifts
to the baron meeting mahayam she knows
about the emperor and the baron's plan
to attack atreides but cannot do
anything because it is the emperor's
order however she asks the baron not to
kill jessica and paul the baron agrees
to do as she says but plans to throw the
two into the sand for the sand worms to
kill back on arrakis a meeting is held
where the officials discuss their plan
to mine the spices it is revealed that
the harkonnens have left them with
damaged equipment setting them up for
failure after a while paul reunites with
duncan who had been sent to prepare for
their arrival duncan says that he has
been living in the desert with the
fremen for four weeks he tells them all
about their ways to survive and also
about a fremen community called a siege
and their leader stilgar stilgar has
also come to meet lado stilgar spits on
the ground which guernie hallock
believes to be an insult but it turns
out to be a show of respect as the
body's moisture is the rarest commodity
on arrakis lato offers him to work
together with the atreides but stilgar
belittles him for taking from their land
without any return to the people they
separate on a good note after lato
promises not to infringe upon their
community before leaving stilgar looks
directly at paul and says that he
recognizes him the next day lato and his
team go to inspect the spice sand that
they will be mining from they meet a
fremen and imperial ecologist named dr
liet kinds she checks the integrity of
lato's still suit which is supposed to
recycle sweat and urine from a person's
body into drinking water while checking
paul's suit kines notices that he
already knows the fremen's way of
wearing the suit despite it being his
first time this makes her think of a
prophecy that says their messiah will
know their ways of life despite being
from another land kynes also believes
paul to be the one after that all of
them leave to inspect the spice stand
while sightseeing they see two sand
worms approaching the harvester that
mines the spice it seems to be a usual
problem as a carrier is sent to lift the
harvester to get it out of the worm's
reach however the carrier's anchor
breaks and it is unable to lift the
machine a crew of 21 are inside the
harvester who are about to be attacked
by the worms lato thinks quickly and
orders everyone to get their aircraft
closer to the device and get the crew on
board they land on the sand minutes
before the worm attacks and manage to
save the crew however paul gets a whiff
of the spice in the process and gets a
vision when he returns home he is still
dizzy and the doctor concludes it is an
allergy however paul claims that he saw
a fremen girl in his vision and he knows
it wasn't just an allergy he also tells
jessica that she is pregnant but jessica
dismisses it the scene then shifts to
the imperial army planet where a
battalion is being prepared to attack
atreides and kill lato and his family
they are called the army of sartikar who
are said to be the deadliest army in the
known world back on arrakis the doctor
brings paul a medicine to help him with
the allergies but little does paul know
the doctor has made a deal with the
baron and the medicine will render paul
unconscious lato and jessica are also
given medicine for their sleep jessica
takes it but lato doesn't after a while
the army of sartikar attacks lato wakes
up and realizes what is happening but
before he can do anything the doctor
hits him with a dart that slowly makes
him unconscious
outside the sartikar army wreaks havoc
in the place taking the atreides army by
surprise since the sardakar is double in
number and has several weapons they soon
overpower the atreides who have been
made sitting ducks by the emperor at the
same time the doctor tells an injured
lato that the baron has abducted his
wife so he had to do what he says the
doctor then takes off plato's ring to
give it to paul he also places a
poisonous molar tooth in lato's jaw
saying that if he bites hard enough the
tooth will secrete poisonous gas and
will kill everyone around him this could
be their only hope of taking down the
baron meanwhile the sartikar army
abducts paul and jessica to throw them
in the desert paul wakes up in an
aircraft with his mother gagged and tied
beside him she can use her power to
manipulate people and make them do what
they are told so the two use their
powers and manage to kill their
abductors paul finds a frem kit placed
by the doctor for their help after that
they escape into the middle of the
desert in the meantime an unconscious
lato is taken to the baron and stripped
naked the doctor asks baron to free his
wife but he is instead killed
mercilessly the baron then tells lato
that his bloodline will end today seeing
no way to escape lato bites onto his
tooth and lets at the poisonous gas that
kills everyone in the room including
himself
somewhere else paul and jessica set up a
tent using the kit they also find a note
from the doctor and lato's ring looking
at the ring the two realize that lato is
dead and cry mourning his death the
following morning duncan idaho
approaches the fremen imperial ecologist
kines and asks her to help look for paul
and jessica back in the barons palace
his soldiers come into the room after
the poisonous gas has faded they're
surprised to see the baron has attached
himself to the ceiling and is somehow
alive at the same time paul trips balls
from the spice in the sand and starts to
get visions of the holy war that is
about to happen in the future he sees
himself killing millions of people and
the deaths make him hyperventilate a
worried jessica calms her son down
some time later he wears his father's
ring taking the title of duke of the
tradies they are soon found by duncan
who kneels in front of paul calling him
the lord duke then all three of them are
taken to a safe place by kinds the place
they are staying at is an old ecological
station that was supposed to provide
flowing water to arrakis if the project
had been successful arrakis would have
been a paradise however before the
project was completed this spice was
discovered in the sand everyone's
attention was diverted towards
harvesting the valuable spice and the
project was dismissed a while later the
sartikar army reaches the safe zone and
attacks everyone duncan puts his life at
risk to save jessica and paul paul yells
at him to stop because he has seen
duncan's death in his vision but duncan
stays put to fulfill his duty eventually
he is killed while fighting the army but
jessica paul and kynes managed to run
away jessica and paul get on an aircraft
that only holds two people meanwhile
kines asks them to head south to meet
the fremen who will help them in their
cause she plans to board an aircraft
from another station the mother and son
fly away but kynes is soon caught by the
sartikar soldiers they are about to kill
her when she makes a rhythmic thumping
on the ground the noise attracts a sand
worm who devours all of them in a single
bite after that paul's aircraft is
chased by two enemy aircraft paul sends
their vehicle into an aggressive
sandstorm making their enemies believe
that they are dead in the following
scene we see the baron bathing in
medicines to heal the injuries caused by
the poisonous gas his nephew rabin
arrives and commends him on his marlon
brando impression he also tells him that
lado and his bloodline are dead finally
happy that his enemy house is destroyed
the baron orders rabin to continue to
harvest the spice and kill all the
fremen somewhere else paul and jessica
crash land in the desert but are safe
they change into their still suits and
begin looking for the fremen to ask them
for help paul had learned about fremen
lives and knows the way they walk to
avoid attracting the worms they walk for
the whole day throughout which paul gets
visions of fremen people and a specific
girl telling him not to give up the two
stop to rest for a while when suddenly
they hear a loud noise paul realizes
that a sand worm is nearby to save their
lives they start to run only to be
chased by the worm even faster it
emerges from the sand and is about to
engulf the two but stops midway someone
had set off a thumper to help them just
then the leader of the fremen stilgar
and his group surround them it is soon
revealed that they plan to kill paul and
jessica for the fluid in their bodies
stilgar stops his men saying that paul
is the messiah they were told about the
others do not believe him saying that
paul has not yet proven himself so he
cannot be the messiah one of them
insults jessica calling her old and a
weakling she proves herself by holding
the man hostage with his life in her
hands after that the leader asks
everyone to make their way to the siege
taber where paul and jessica's fate will
be determined just then the girl from
paul's visions arrives in front of him
and introduces herself as chaney as they
prepare to leave one freman named jameis
insists on having a duel with paul in
fremont tradition all duels must end
with someone's death paul who has been
training all his life easily defeats
jameis but he hesitates to kill him
because he hasn't killed anyone in his
life at last paul stabs the man to death
and wins the fight then the others pack
the dead body and make their way to the
siege taber the movie ends when paul
sees a man riding a massive sand worm
and chani tells him it is only the
beginning the ending of the movie makes
it clear that there is much more to come
in the sequel
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications thanks for watching